each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so I were very very happy to have Daniel
which here so most of us know Daniel
he's been an intern with us and he's
from NYU supervised by live games of
this and he's done really wonderful work
in crypto some of his really beautiful
stuff has to do with our leaky and
temporary zillion photography which is
what he's in about today alright thanks
Yale so i'll be talking about
cryptography with week noisy leaky and
tempered keys essentially all kinds of
bad things can happen to your key can
you still do crypto so we all know that
cryptography require secret key is
because if you can decrypt messages
intended for you and you don't have any
secrets and everyone else could decrypt
as well that would be bad so we need
secret keys and the way we usually think
about these is that when we design a
scheme we specify how the keys are
chosen what the distribution is and how
they are you so the skin tells you
exactly what you should do with the key
and essentially so everything's under
our control and the attacker is no other
acts as no other way of getting
information about the key other than
what we specify when we design the
scheme other than kind of interacting
with the scheme and so this talk is
about kind of scenarios where that might
not be the case so for example you might
want to use a password or biometric as a
secret key and we can't tell you how to
choose your biometric you kind of have
to use what you are given or you can
even yeah maybe eventually or you know
you might even choose your secret key
really honestly and and as we specify
but then when you use the secret gear
can be some leakage or the attacker can
get some extra information this is
through things like side-channel attacks
I'll explain what that is later and
lastly at least if I found out logos
about potential biscuit he's getting
modifier tampered again beyond what you
want or what you have control over and
so the main question for this talk is
can reconstruct crypto systems that
remain secure even with these kind of
imperfect
geez where we don't have full control
over the distribution or what what the
attacker can can learn and so the focus
on the stock the task I want to focus on
is just secure communication so this is
kind of the bread and butter of
cryptography so we have a user Alice and
she just wants to communicate securely
with another another user Bob over at
public and completely insecure Channel
that's controlled by some attacker Eve
and the two properties we want our first
of all privacy so even if Eve observes
the communication over this channel she
shouldn't learn anything about the
message and second of all authentication
so even if Eve is active and tries to
modify the contents of the channel she
shouldn't be able to get Bob to accept
the message that didn't actually come
from Alice so she can't insert or modify
the messages over the channel so those
are the two two things we want and so
the first question we're going to ask is
can we actually get information
theoretic security using a shared vici
ok so information theoretic security is
the kind of security and studied in the
40s it means that secure actually holds
statistically even if the attacker is
can run an exponential time is all
powerful in terms of computation still
security should hold and so with
information theoretic security the best
we can hope for is that kind of with one
use of the key Alice can only send a
single short message to Bob and that's
what we're going to look at and the
setting where ian is that Alice and Bob
start out by sharing what I'll call a
weekly random key so what that means for
this dog is that we don't know what the
distribution of the key is will in fact
okay not kind of assume it's adversarial
the attacker chooses the distribution
that this initial secret that Alice and
Bob started with comes from it so he
doesn't choose the secrets of it uses
the distribution the only guarantee
property we have on this distribution is
that it has it should have some
sufficient level of entropy so it should
be hard to predict a sample from this
distribution with good probability so
that that seems kind of necessary
otherwise it's not really secret if we
can predict it and so hopefully this
should model things like passwords or
biometrics where we just don't know too
much about the distribution of these
come
from so you might as well assume that
it's adversarial because we really don't
know much much else about it it should
also model things like partially key so
we start with a uniformly random key and
then the attacker can learn some
information about it even information of
the attacker chooses what to learn as
long as the amount is not too large
let's say the attacker learns like three
fourth of the key then are conditioned
on on on the leaked information the key
still has some entropy but the
distribution is kind of chosen by the
attacker depends on the leakage so so
the first question we can ask is there
just a general method that lets us
convert a wiki into a strong uniformly
random cryptographic key can we just do
something generic like that and there's
actually a tool that that's designed for
this purpose that lets us do this call
random s extractor defined by Nissan and
Zekrom in 96 and this is a function that
takes a week secret W and somehow
extracts out a uniformly random key so
that's great except there's a catch the
catch is that in order to do this the
extractor also need some additional are
uniformly random seed so you can think
of it as some helper data that you need
in order to extract out the uniform
value and so the good good news is that
the seat can be made public so you can
tell everyone what the see this and the
property you get is that no matter what
distribution what week distribution w
comes from the extracted key k looks
uniformly random it looks like a
uniformly random value even given the
seed even conditioned on seeing the seat
sometimes also called strong random this
extractor but that's all we'll consider
here and so these extractors have real a
lot of uses on complexity theory in
cryptography and here's kind of one used
they give us one a solution to this
problem kind of right away and the
solution is that when we design the
scheme we just choose a seed X at the
beginning of time so maybe Microsoft
wants to design a scheme and says
everyone you should use the seed X
that's what we chose and that's the seat
for everyone and we kind of hard coded
into all protocols so whenever somebody
writes a protocol they'll do pound
defined seed equals and you know they're
all use the same seat
and then if you want to if you want to
use a week secret for cryptography the
first thing you do is just extract out a
uniformly random key out of it and then
use that then do whatever you would do
with a uniformly random key so this kind
of completely gets around week secrets
there's two problems with this solution
so the first problem is that the users
would need to trust that the CDX what
was actually chosen honestly by
Microsoft right so you have to trust
Mike return my crow soft shows it
uniformly at random so some people might
not like to do that they want just a
single scheme that we all know works not
kind of some randomly chosen scheme the
second problem is that this only works
if the distribution that that the secret
w comes from is cannot depend on the C
deck so in some sense the idea here is
that first attacker chooses the
distribution then Microsoft uses the
seed and and then you choose a sample
from this distribution and that might be
okay for passwords or biometrics because
that's kind of a fixed distribution
probably it's not like people are
adaptively choosing their biometric
depending on some seed but it's bad for
things like leakage because if the
attacker can choose what to leak then
the leakage can depend on the seed of
the extractor itself so the attacker can
can actually they target it kind of at
that particular seed and all bets are
off if you if you try to do this then
the extracted randomness might not be
actually uniform so here's another
solution that kind of seems to solve
this problem or get get around these
problems so instead of having having the
seed hard-coded and having kind of one
seed for everyone why don't we let Alice
choose the seat so she first chooses the
seed and then she extracts out
randomness at her and she sent it over
to Bob and he uses it to extract out
randomness on his end um so okay this
actually kind of works if you care about
privacy Alice then uses this key to
encrypt a message to Bob and Eve is just
passively observing the communication
then this works because even condition
on seeing the seed are the extracted he
looks uniformly random so that's good
the problem is that this doesn't work if
Eve is active and can modify things over
channel so for authentication this
doesn't work the problem is that if can
just modify the seed and cause give Bob
it completely different incorrect seed
and cause both to to extract some bad
key K Prime and all better off about k
prime it's possible that if can even
choose this bad seed in such a way that
she completely knows k prime okay so she
can get Bob to extract a completely bad
he and then that's bad she can
authenticate messages to Bob analysis
behalf under this bed p and convince Bob
that they came from Alice so this
completely breaks authentication right
yeah I'm thinking now for now that alice
is sending the message to Bob so Vallas
is using the key to send message to Bob
then secrecy's okay yeah if it went the
other way you write it would also break
secrecy so the question is so this
particular protocol doesn't work but is
there some other way can you affect akay
tam message to another person if you
only have a shared vici so is there some
protocol for doing that and so in a
joint work with notice we actually
showed that this cannot generally be
done in one round of communication so if
L is just wants to send one message to
Bob and convince him that kind of this
message came from her you cannot do it
you cannot have a protocol like this so
this is something you can do if you have
a uniformly random key in fact just
using pairwise independent hash function
this works but with wikis it actually
cannot be done on the other hand we show
actually there's a two-round protocol so
just a protocol where Bob first and some
challenge to Alice and then Alice are
sent something to Bob and convinces him
authenticate a message to him in the
second round ok and so I'll show you a
little bit about this two round protocol
I just wanted to mention prior to this
actually people had protocols for how to
do this but with many rounds of
communications so actually the number of
rounds was in constant was proportional
to the level of security you want it and
practice something like hundred or you
know hundreds of rounds so I think the
main main thing about the proko that
I'll present is that it's conceptual a
lot simpler it has a really nice
structure and leads to like a very
simple question
about extractors so here's here's the
main idea and the main idea is to just
reverse things so actually have Bob
choose the seed X and send it over to
Alice in the first round and then Alice
and Bob use the C to extract out
randomness from their week from their
joint week secret and then in the second
round Alice uses some standard method
for authenticated message with that with
a uniformly random key ok so so we just
really reverse the way things work here
and why is this better why would this
make sense why is this somehow better
for active attacks so let's assume that
Eve is active and she actually modifies
the seed in the first round ok so she's
going to send the wrong seed so now kind
of all bets are off about the randomness
that Alice extract right this could be
bad the key that Alice uses but Bob
still has the right key and he's the one
that checks whether the authentication
is correct or incorrect so somehow if he
wants to forge in the second round she
needs to forge a huge the authenticated
message under the right key so that's
good there's still a problem that alice
is key k prime might be bad so it's not
a problem if it's just if it's a key
that let's say the attacker knows
because because she's just a forged
under the original key which is strong
and so just seeing some information
about a key that she knows doesn't
really help her but the problem here is
if Alice's key K prime is actually in
some bad sense related to the key K so
somehow alice is getting si if somehow
he is getting Alice to use an incorrect
key to do the authentication which might
be related to the correct one and using
that you can learn some extra
information that lets her you know forge
messages or break the protocol in the
second round in some sense you can think
of this as an attack actually where
where you can actually tamper with
Alice's key K prime by somehow modifying
the seat so i'll talk about tampering
attacks later but somehow this even
though it's not real that the goal isn't
tampering or it's not like eva stamp
regalis iski directly somehow it
translates into tampering attack yeah
implication but there's no privacy for
now I'm just looking at doing the
question of authentication once you do
that it's actually easy to combine it to
get both privacy and authentication at
the same time into around here yeah the
idea is you authenticate a new seed in
the second round and then it's if
there's some complications with doing
that because there are you know you are
using the same key for many things you
have to be a yeah yeah so liver yeah you
have to well things aren't completely
different because they all come from the
same source but but but it does
essentially work right because I mean if
you extracted out to different Keats 4w
there they're not huh but but yeah it is
pretty easy to just stick it on top yeah
I think your addition works no no Justin
just in two rounds like that so yeah
just in the to do that just in the
second round the message that the
authentic aid is just a new seat for an
extractor and then you know you can use
that that key to do everything so yeah
but I just want to focus on
authentication it's really the hard part
here okay so yeah so the problem is that
you know by modifying the seed v's gets
the temper the key K prime that Alice's
uses and unless we analyze some
properties of the extractor we just have
no idea what this stamp ring will look
like or what kind of tampering attack
this translates into so so so on a high
level the problem is that if you see a
random seed X for an extractor and can
choose a related seed X prime somehow
based on X then the extracted values are
using the seed X and X prime are somehow
related to each other in some bad sense
that we we don't know much about and so
the main question that we ask ourselves
is are there extractors for which we can
say something interesting about this
relationship for which we can somehow
analyzed with how k and k prime are
related to each other so essentially say
that the tampering attack is not too bad
it's it's limited what
if can do we call these non-value
extractors and we have we actually
showed have two results so first first
result is actually there there's such a
thing as a fully non malleable extractor
even if you see the CDX and choose an
arbitrarily related to X prime the
randomness that you extract that
experiments completely unrelated to the
randomness you would extract that X so
even if you see it you don't learn
anything about what you should have
extracted so exactly yeah hey loads
uniform even given K Prime and that's
great if you plug that into the perk on
the last value you're done you get
security because by modifying the seed
the attacker doesn't get anything but
the function is known right so it's like
it's not totally you mean you mean
random function for the extractor yeah
that's actually the concern you know
that that's our proof we have a non
constructive proof
the randomness is known yes it's not you
know it's not completely true but
follows the same kind of proof that
standard extractors exist you just have
to analyze this this extra malleability
property but yeah what we should end up
showing is that just a random function
has this property but of course a random
function isn't kind of efficient we not
have efficient description so it's a non
constructive proof we don't actually
have an instantiation so instead we show
a slightly weaker property some some we
call it somewhat not malleable and I
don't want to get too much into details
but essentially we show that the
relationship between K and K prime is
somehow limited and and this property
turns out to be sufficient for the for
the program the last side so it lets us
lets us solve that problem I think it's
still an interesting question if fully
not malleable extractors exist and I
know people are working on it so I'm
hoping that there will be a construction
soon so if yeah it depends on what the
somewhat is or so and the fully there's
no relationship so even if you see and
the some what it's like a complicated
thing that somehow there the extracted
randomness is somehow divided into
blocks and you can say like the first
block of the modified keys unrelated to
you know the second log of the original
or something like that so it becomes not
a super nice relationship but something
that you can reason about and then can
build that authentication protocol on
top of it can actually use you know you
can reason somehow about this this
relationship and build things from it
no it's as we use kind of known
extractors in a somewhat blackbox sense
to build build another kind of extractor
but it's it's it's not not any known
extractor or we don't have any nice
analysis for how known extractors behave
under these modification attacks we have
to construct something somewhere is
really some of the entity
um yeah the consequence of the somewhat
is that you have to actually build a
more complicated authentication protocol
because you know your authentication
there is still some relationship between
the keys so you have to build an
authentication protocol at secure so
sorry kind of this second round
authentication scheme that you use has
to be secure even against some limited
modification of K prime right so so you
have to do something more complicated
there you can just use one straight up
but the end result actually ends up
being here you lose a little bit and in
the in the entropy so you need to assume
the week secret starts up with more
entropy than you get at the end that's
the end result
yeah it's depending on the security para
so not nothing related to the size of
the seeker anything just depend the
level of security you want yeah okay and
so um so let's actually look at an
application of this letter you actually
wanted to use this with biometrics so
let's imagine a scenario where Alice has
some biometric like let's say
fingerprint and initially she registers
with some you can think of it as I guess
some sort of service Bob so she gives
him her in an initial scan of this
biometric and and he keeps that and
later she wants to communicate the box
she'll take a fresh scan of her
biometric the problem so can we use the
proko straight out well the problem is
that usually we take scans of a
biometric they're not exactly the same
there's some errors so Alice's second
scan w problem will not be exactly the
same as W and and there's actually an
idea for how to handle this which is
that Bob sent some sort of also a sketch
of the secret w that lets Alice correct
out the errors and you can actually do
this in some clever way that you send a
sketch it lets us correct out errors
without revealing too much information
about W so that's that's actually kind
of clever schemes that people thought
about for how to do this and and again
this like right away let you get passive
security but if you care about active
attacks then now it gets one more chance
to modify things she can now modify the
sketch as well so you have to also
handle the fact that you can modify the
seed and the sketch together it kind of
gives them more tampering of the key K
prime that Alice extract and in fact the
the kind of the way we handle this was a
fairly general method for handling
linearly temple tampered keys the main
idea is that most of these sketches are
actually linear so when you try to use
an incorrect sketch it just translates
into a very simple kind of tampering
attack where the key K prime is offset
by some known constant and this you
actually kind of came up with pretty
general ways of handling this that that
seemed to have a lot of other uses so
there also will be useful when I
actually talk about real tampering
attacks late
on okay I think actually is so this is
kind of a biometrics I think this could
be useful for four and a lot of other
applications so one thing I was thinking
about it maybe we wanted to establish
like a shared key between two cell
phones you could take them together and
shake them and just take the motion data
of the cell phones and you know this
motion data probably is a lot of entropy
and it's probably not exactly the same
but it's going to be correlated and so
that's something you could probably use
these types of techniques to correct out
the errors and establish a real key out
of it distance yes I didn't say much
about the distance it isn't some metric
and we do us some some distance
generally like what people do is they
take let's say biometric scan and they
extract out some features so they create
a feature vector and then if you take to
close readings they are actually closed
over Hamming distance so you can even
use codes / Hamming distance and they're
meaningful in the sense of biometrics
yeah yeah that's a good question
okay so now I want to move on to kind of
the next topic which is so now we saw
how to do information theoretic
symmetric key cryptography can we do
public key cryptography with weak or
leaky keys and here I'll actually focus
more on more in the case of leakage
although the techniques usually work for
for a key that starts out we weekly
random as well so so the scenario here
is that we want to have a have an
encryption scheme which is secure even
if the attacker can leak some partial
information about the secret key so we
assume the secret key and the public
your chosen kind of correctly as
specified but then the attacker can
choose any kind of F information about
the secret key to leak as long as the
size of the information or the size of
the leakage is not too large let's say
less than ninety percent of the key can
leak and so this is an area that that
there's been a lot of work in in the
past two years I think so so actually it
started with the work of a caveat
Goldwasser Mike and telephone they did
encryption schemes and then we showed
how to do signature schemes in this
setting and then people have studied all
kinds of different how to do it under
different assumptions and kind of
different types of schemes and some
variants of these models and I think
these are interesting but it gets a
little technical so I'm not actually
going to tell you too much about the
construction of these schemes instead I
want to focus on like kind of an
application or very end of this model
that I think is interesting and so the
application is the main question for
this application is is security
necessarily lost if a machine that
stores cryptographic key is infected
with that with a virus can you get any
kind of security if your if your machine
is has a virus on it and so the model is
that we have some computer that stores a
secret key for a cryptographic scheme
and we have a remote attacker somewhere
in I don't know Belarus or somewhere far
away that can just download arbitrary
information from this compromise machine
so can download whatever whatever it
wants can you kind of maintain any kind
of security in this setting and so I
think an idea that's interesting for how
to do this is to just make the secret
key huge so make your secret keys like a
hundred gigabytes and then try to use a
scheme that secure
even if ninety percent of the key leaks
so here's the idea for why that might be
might be useful so in order for the
attacker to break security right
actually break the scheme the tech we
will need to not download at least 90
gigabytes worth of information and that
might be kind of hard to do because you
know maybe bandwidth this to slower it
would cost too much to download 9 8
gigabytes especially we wanted to do
this attack on that on a very large
scale you have to download 9 8 gigabytes
from each compromised machine or it
might be just easier to detect leaking
90 gigabytes worth of data ok and on the
other hand the storage goes to the user
for storing 100 gigabytes is really not
that large it's like five dollars you
know you think you I estimates but ok so
there's a problem the problem is that if
you try to use kind of a standard scheme
you'd also get giant computation times
and public keys and all kinds of other
things so you definitely can't expect a
user to do some complicated computation
over 100 gigabyte key to sign a sign a
message that's completely unreasonable
so what we'd really like is to have a
scheme where where the secret key can
grow we can make the secret key you know
100 gigabytes but only the secret key
grows and everything else stays
efficient so the public you stay small
kind of the same size as normal crypto
schemes and the computation plans remain
small so for example if you want to sign
a message you can't even read the entire
secret key to do that ah and so that's
something we looked at for ya so for
signatures it's like signing the message
and verifying the message for encryption
schemes to be decrypting the message
encrypting it yet and so so this idea
can we have these efficient schemes with
huge keys um and so I want to tell you a
little bit about an idea for how to
actually construct those just kind of a
very high-level idea and that is let's
say we start out i'll do it for
signatures for now it's easier to think
about but let's say we start with a
signature scheme that kind of has normal
small keys you know depending on how
much security you want to get that are
resilient to ninety percent of leakage
can you construct the scheme with a much
bigger team that's resilient to kind of
this more leakage on an absolute scale
that's a same percentage here's an idea
let's just take many copies of the
scheme so choose many independent secret
keys and public keys and let Alice store
all of the secret key so you know
hundred thousand see cookies whatever
gets you 200 gigabytes I don't know how
many that is and Alice will store this
whole database of secret keys for now
Bob relax also store database of public
key so we'll solve that later now the
public you will be huge this is just the
first step and then in order to sign
Alice will just create a signature under
each one of the key so here the
computation time is also large and we'll
solve that later also but the question
is does this scheme just taking many
copies of a signature scheme does that
actually tolerate more leakage on an
absolute sense does it all airy ninety
percent leakage on the combined secret
key if each one is is secure for ninety
percent on the small one and the
intuition says yes because if you leak
less than ninety percent of the big
secret key there should be at least one
little secret key on which you'll eat
less than ninety percent you have less
than ninety percent information and so
if the attacker can't sign under that
one she can't sign under the whole
secret key right because she has to sign
she has to sign under each one so the
signature here is to sign under each key
it's not efficient yet will will solve
that a second but here's here the first
idea is just can we get a scheme with
more leakage forget about efficiency can
we get a ski with bigger piece and more
leakage if we have a schema with small
keys and some small amount of leakage
and so the intuition says that this
should work um but interesting that you
actually start doing the proof it
doesn't it doesn't seem to to go through
because there's just no natural way to
convert a leakage on the big combined
key and to leakage on each of the little
key so somehow the reduction doesn't
seem to go through and so what we ended
up showing is that it actually holds for
some specific schemes and we thought
that there should be counter examples
but we didn't actually know how to do
them and people people really like this
problem so recently there's been two
works that show counter examples to this
to this lemma so kind of they construct
a small scheme that's secure against 90
leakage but we take many independent
copies of the scheme then you can break
it with with much less leakage than just
multiply it out saying that exactly
ninety percent of the bits are leaked or
news and functions some complicated
function yeah leakage is a complicated
function here it's not just but if it's
bits then this works yeah yeah the point
is that leakage can be an arbitrary kind
of related information about the key so
you know the virus can do some pre
computation and meet whatever it wants
there's some sort of well-defined sons
in which you can lead say ninety-five
percent of each of the small key is but
only ninety percent of them collectively
I mean I'm willing to believe to do
something goes wrong in the proof but
I'm really curious okay no the intuition
is that there's some sense in which when
you leak in ninety percent on the
combined key so you can kind of
adaptively choose the leakage on the
keys based on each other it's not
equivalent to leaking just individual in
you know ninety percent on each key or
even that there's no sense in which you
can say that there's a single key on
which less than ninety percent was
leaked I guess that's that's really the
main intuition you can somehow real
adaptively the leakage is kind of a
global function i guess on all the keys
together and that really helps you out
yeah I think even there or there there
it's always actually yeah so there's
some so I think one of the counter
examples like even if you you know if
you take n copies you expect the leakage
to amplify n times the absolute amount
of leakage and you can tolerate and it
says that you can leak like n over 2
times as much leakage and and break the
scheme always so yeah I think I think
there's going to be there's also acting
counter examples where where you know it
really doesn't grow almost at all beyond
not multi like beyond some threshold it
just doesn't if you keep taking more
scheme it won't the amount of leakage
you can tolerate won't grow this is
raven sting for
broadcast and join keys from satellites
ah there is yeah yeah so this is that's
called the bondage storage well people
call this the boundary of treatment
model so it is similar in that sense
there there's a maybe like in how how
people so there's a lot of similarity in
the techniques especially but in terms
of the ideas I guess they're you think
people have actually small storage but
there's somehow this huge key in the sky
here you think people have large storage
but there's some leakage on idea limited
communication so it's kind of the
opposite conceptually but the techniques
there's some relationship in techniques
actually this relationship will kind of
be be in this part more so so this
scheme is still not efficient right I
still you know this the public is huge
the computation times are huge so I
still didn't tell you how to do that and
it turns out it's pretty easy to make
the public key small so this can be done
generically using certificate so you
kind of sign all the public keys under
some other public key that's not to
complicate it to just just reduce the
public key size but still you have to
sign under each one of the secret keys
um and so to get rid of that actually
the the main idea and this is something
people did in the bounded storage model
as well is so I find all these guys I
communicate yeah in the signature so so
so when so you sign all of the secret
keys with a mess with kind of a big
master public key or something and then
when alice is asked to sign a message
she says oh this is this is my signature
under public key one in position one and
here's the public in position one and a
certificate that this is the right
public key for position one
well not huge I mean just as a small
city so that's the second step right
yeah yeah so right now I didn't make it
much more huge but it's it's it's huge
just as it was to begin with and now to
reduce the size the main ideas that you
don't sign under all the keys if I
bought chooses some random subset of
them and at least on an intuitive scale
he should hit some some subset of the
keys that that you didn't learn too much
on but again the intuition kind of
doesn't break down generically but for
specific schemes this actually does work
so that's what we ended up showing so
some of these specific schemes the
analysis is very information theoretic
and then you can you can kind of
information tharok that this stuff works
so you can show that that it works for
them
you can ask your family story to get all
this stuff it seemed like he wasn't
doing public key schemes right he was
doing stuff that's unconditionally
secure so it turns out like the analysis
of public keys is complete so somehow
information theoretically it's pretty
clear that this stuff works when you
have computation assumption if to do
reductions you get you run into exactly
the types of problems that you know
things don't generally work particular
things you know that they don't work
generally yeah yeah you stop doing
something wrong with information here at
execution you have to apply special
schemes to right right ah and it turns
out that similar techniques time i did
in terms of signatures you can use
similar techniques for encryption you
know you can encrypt the same message
under each key that's actually bad you
instead encrypt like it part a share of
the message under different keys but
kind of the same same main idea okay so
I switch topics once again a little bit
and metrics can we do cryptography with
essentially under side-channel attacks
and what you'll see it'll translate to
something called continual leakage on
the secret key so here's the main idea
usually when we think again when we
think in theory about what a
cryptographic algorithm is it's just
some you know there's some algorithm
their secret keys in this algorithm and
the attacker can give it inputs and gets
outputs and that's all the attacker sees
then when you actually try to implement
this you'll put this algorithm on a
physical device um things go a little
bit wrong because there's kind of more
there so for example you could take the
time measure the time that the device
needs to run the algorithm that can
reveal some information about the
internals you know you could try to
measure the electricity that uses or
even the sound that it emits all kinds
of radiation so essentially just on a
high level the problem is these things
are called side-channel attacks and the
problem is that there's some observable
physical properties of the device that
can reveal information or partial
information about what's going on on the
inside a and so so fine so side channel
attack is some partial leakage of the
internals of the computation we just
told you you know I just told you that
we can handle
so are we done well no there's a problem
it's partial leakage / use of the scheme
each time you kind of called the
algorithm there's there's leakage you
know you call it on different input
there's more leakage and so eventually
if you kind of keep using the scheme and
leaking a little bit about what's going
on you can leak the entire key so that's
bad but okay but that's unless maybe the
right idea here is that actually each
time the scheme does something it should
also update its its internal key okay
and then maybe with these updates if you
leak on the different you kind of leak
on what's going on in the inside but the
key isn't consistently the same so
there's always a different key you won't
actually be able to somehow combine the
leakage to to actually do something
useful so that's the main idea here and
so that's something we studying a joint
work with the Otis and Harlan be a van
and gianna lopez alt and we introduce a
kind of a new model either there's also
been a lot of preceding work to be I'm
ignoring but a new model where the
secret keys can be we have a scheme a
public key scheme at a signature scheme
where the secret key can just be updated
at any point in time so the skin can
just update it secret key in some
meaningful way and when this update
happens it doesn't really affect how the
scheme work so the public he stays the
same the signatures it produces are
still the same as before they kind of
verify under the same public key so
nothing really changes from the point of
view functionality just the key somehow
looks different okay and the idea is
that the attacker can get partial
information on each on a partial leakage
on each key so at any kind of at any
point in time can get partial
information about the state of the
system but but then the state gets
refreshed and and this keeps happening
so ah so let me actually illustrate it
just I think you'll see what I'm talking
about so initially there's the device
store some initial secret key and the
attacker let's say there's a signature
scheme so the tackle gives it a message
and the device outputs a signature and
as this is happening the factor gets
some partial information so this like
broken version of the key get some
partial information about the
and then let's say the key at the end of
the signature the key is updated the
attacker gives he gives the scheme a new
message and the the scheme process
signature gets a some leakage on this
update a key and this kind of keeps
happening so it keeps getting a leakage
on each of the in each period kind of on
the state of the device and and this can
go on as however long you want there's
no bond for kind of how many uses of the
scheme that I could get there's only
bound on the amount of leakage you can
get at each use and so eventually you
know you can try to combine the leakage
on these various keys and the main
property here is that you shouldn't be
able to combine them in a meaningful way
to be able to forge a signature of a new
message you shouldn't be able to produce
a signature and anything you haven't
seen yet I mean the keys are also
evolving right so I could try to come up
with the things they look after and
while this looking or the key would be
and so the I guess you don't you don't
know the randomness it's going to be the
evolving is actually randomized and you
don't know the randomness that's going
to be used in in the future evolutions
space officially of the
come from can I just claim that as an
instructor can I claim oh there was this
random nurse which led to the following
key and now so sorry I'm so sure the
oh I see so the public key is being sort
of fixed yeah the public he sticks
throughout everyone knows the public key
and each of the secret keys is kind of a
good secret key it works right it's for
the same public key but somehow yes so
at the time you know when you're leaking
on at any given point of time when
you're leaking about the state of the
device you don't know what the state is
going to be in the next time period
because there's some fresh randomness
coming in to the issue your issue is
you're saying in spite of all this
leakage from all all these difference in
your keys I still can't make a new
secret any secret key right ok so what
models may be saying or I don't know but
if the updates that's exact I'm saying
but if the updates were deterministic
then it would fail at least with this
general mod of leakage we can leak
anything you want about the key because
you could always yeah or actually even a
signature not just you win not not only
if you make a valid secret key whenever
you actually porch a signature when you
mess around so even even more right
right so yeah that's a stronger it's a
kind of movies right yeah there's lots
of out see cookies and you get leakage
on each one but you can't combine in a
meaningful way that's the main idea and
so so this is something so we in this
work we showed how to do signatures and
and some key agreement and some other
other related tasks in this kind of a
model and there's been a lot of exciting
work in this area just in the past year
so actually concurrently with our work
there was a work by brookhurst suika
Brock rescues an intern here and the
alkali and others and there's been a
that the encryption schemes also so
there's more schemes now there's kind of
stronger properties how much you can
leak on the other various updates and
things like that so I think this model
is evolving and there's a lot of
exciting work here and there's much more
to do so I actually want to mention two
things so one thing that that I think
would be really interesting is so far
people really analyze how much leakage
the skin can tolerate but they haven't
analyzed at all how much leakage the
scheme actually generates so I
what what you need in practice that the
scheme needs to tolerate more leakage
then it actually generates when you run
the signing algorithm so yeah so that's
exactly that's one of the problems
people didn't really know how to do this
because we don't know how much leakage
or what kind of leakage is available but
I think a reasonable model would be to
say that the leakage on our scales with
complexity so if your scheme is very
complex and I don't know exactly what
measure of complexity to use here but
somehow have your scheme like makes 200
passes over the key reason many times
and does something complicated it should
leak more and people kind of have not
have ignored that issue so i think the
solutions actually often make more
complex schemes and then if the scheme
actually if complexity leagues have kind
of more than more complex if you have
the more leakage there is then we might
actually be making things less secure so
that would be bad I think that's an
important question to tackle and the
other question I think would be real
interesting so far people have really
thought about this for some general for
some specific cryptosystems but would be
really nice is just to take any
computation anything you want to do
let's say a complicated voting machine
or something like that and make it
secure against against leakage I'm not
sure exactly if in this model you might
kind of think of different models of
leakage or things like that but I think
that's and people are working on this so
far they have some solutions with like
secure hardware or some restricted
models but I think this is also an
exciting area to work on and how much
time I've so there's one more topic and
talk about it okay all right so the last
question that I want to ask this can we
protect secrets against tampering
attacks what if the fact you can
actually modify the state of the system
let me kind of start with an example so
let's say we have this attacker even
again we have this signature token so
she gets a signature token that has a
secret key in it but this time it will
do something a little different it also
has an ID so it has our ID equals Eve
and each time she gives that message the
signature token appends Eve's ID so it
says okay this is a message with even
signs it and what he really wants to do
is she wants to sign something that says
you know that corresponds to a different
user so you can think of there's a lot
of users that all are getting these
signature tokens with the same secret
key but different I
okay and so so Eve has has her token
it's as if she wants to sign something
under a different user how can how can
she forge well if all she has is really
access to the device you can really just
give messages and see signatures then
there's nothing she can do this is
actually secure right that just follows
from the property of signature she can't
porch under a different user and so one
things you could do is do such a meta
tags and then if you use the signature
schemes we talked about from the last
section maybe that offer some protection
so that's kind of the main idea there
but here's another type of attack maybe
she could try to tamper with the with
the device and just kind of like change
the last letter you know with some
powerful laser from an ETA so now the
scheme stores that you know ID equals
eva and just by using the device
correctly feeding get a message you can
then Forge get a signature for for a
different user so this is this is a
tampering attack she's actually
modifying that the idea is that if can
maybe modify even in some pretty simple
or unsophisticated way the state of the
device so that using the device
afterwards thus those bad things that's
the main idea here and actually there's
just a really nice work by Boneta me on
lip not showed that if these signatures
are RSA signatures then just by
introducing random faults while the
signatures being computed and then
seeing the the signature at the end you
can actually factor the RSA modules you
can completely break the scheme so these
attacks so you know you might even like
put the put the device in a microwave or
something and get some random errors and
actually that that would let you break
things
whew blur yeah I know it's important if
few random kind of false yeah yeah if
you just override it with random stuff
you're not going to get anything useful
it's to find out what the signing please
well I the one the game is to forge a
signature under the current user and so
there's still mad two methods in which
you can do that to tampering attacks i
want to give two examples so one is
again this is what you want to what it
comes with what counts as a break is you
pick the secret key or you managed to
force something again you are just ready
so the president's are that you can get
to change your name from trying to do
yeah so the first result you don't get
the secret key but you get a signature
hundred different users that so that
that's bad I want to prevent that as
well the next result you actually get
even the secret key so it's a maybe even
a worse attack but my preferred to be
worse yeah of course my consider be
attack to be easier also yeah yeah of
course yeah I just yeah you're right so
you know these are the first attack
would kind of work for any signature
scheme so I guess what the first attack
shows that it's not it's not necessarily
enough to just secure the signature
scheme you have to secure the whole the
whole thing so I think that's the main
idea and so here's kind of an idea of a
solution it's pretty imperfect but the
main idea is to store the the actual
state of the device in some encoded form
so as a code word and then each time the
device is run it actually decodes it and
then runs the actual computation and so
we'll assume the tampering kind of only
happens in this in the static State kind
of when before you know before the
device execute so maybe it's easier to
tamper with the long-term memory then
like while the device is actually
computing so will only consider actually
tampering on the on the code word itself
and also leads a nice Theory question
about coding scheme so that's that's
always the important thing but the idea
here is that so so so a tampering attack
is really modeled as some family of
functions where the functions map code
words the code words and some and some
of your way
so so the originally the device stores
the code word C the attacker can kind of
choose some function in this and this
family and apply it to the code word and
the device stores f of C and so maybe to
write it even more as kind of a standard
coding problem here is that here you can
think of it as a channel so we have a
source message it's encoded there's a
code word and then the channel apply
some function from the family to the
code word gets a temperate code word and
then that is decoded okay so this is
kind of you can think of tampering as a
as it as a noisy channel or some sort of
a channel and so there's two questions
we have to ask what does it actually
mean to protect against tampering
attacks what are the properties that we
want of this coding scheme and while
what type of tampering attacks are what
families of attacks can you protect
against and so the first thing is well
maybe the what it means to protect
against Tampa attacks is the kind of the
standard error correction or detection
that actually when you decode you'll
figure out it bears were introduced or
can maybe even correct them out probably
correcting out isn't needed so detection
might be enough but I want to say that
even actually a detection is already too
strong of a property and because it's
too strong you can only choose this for
kind of fairly limited classes of
tampering attacks so for example think
of like tampering allows you to just
override the code word with a completely
arbitrary value that you choose to
yourself but it's independent with the
code word religion so you can kind of
zero out the device or just completely
change it then you can always put in
some valid codeword of your choice so
you know that won't be detected you
can't achieve detection for this type of
fairly simple tampering attacks so and
on the other hand it's not really a bad
attack it doesn't make the car do
anything that you couldn't do yourself
to begin with so it's not going to let
you do anything useful so so in a joint
work with Adam basking petra shock we
kind of interest this new notion of code
security which we call nan malleability
and the idea is that if you tamper with
the code word then the the mess
stored in the tampered code which you
just either be the same as the original
or unrelated to the original so you
can't kind of cause the device to do
something related to what it was
supposed to do but in a bad way and
that's exactly what so we kind of also
show that this is exactly what you need
to protect against against these types
of tampering attacks right so to make
sure that if you tamper with the device
in this and the signs of tampering with
the with the code word you won't get a
value that somehow useful let you break
something that you couldn't do before
yeah exactly can't use linear codes
everything like that is off limits yeah
because well it depends again what types
of attacks but if you consider let's say
even the simple family of functions
where you can add a known offset you can
do linear codes yeah and so one thing to
show is actually that non malleable
codes exist for every small end of
family of functions so if you choose any
kind of family of functions to begin
with as long as there are some
sufficient number of things you can't do
so the family isn't like the family of
all functions map encoder it's a code
word it's a it's at least asymptotically
smaller than that you can come up with
that with a non valuable code that that
protects against this family of
tampering unfortunately again this is
non construct its kind of necessarily
non-constructive because we say that
even for all polynomial time things we
have non valuable codes but of course
there's kind of always an attack that
just you know the function of the code
word actually decodes it adds like
changes the last bit of the message and
then rien codes it right so this is
there's always a malleability attack
that you could potentially do and so
then we also give some constructions for
concrete examples so one of the examples
is exactly this where you can you can
temper any number of bits of the code
word you want but for each bid you do it
independently so for the first bid you
say ok I want to flip this bit for the
second bid you can so you can flip it so
you can also kind of like set them to be
the set it to be a constant so you can
say the second bit i want to set it to 0
so you can completely overwrite the co
includes like a text where you
completely override the code word with
whatever you choose it includes like
adding known offsets thanks
that and so for that we have we have
actually constructive constructive
version but of course there's there's a
lot of open questions like how to do
this for constructively for more general
families and that'd be really
interesting and and all kinds of
questions are not known like what's the
optimal rates things that like coding
theories would like you know generally
ass about about kind of coding questions
we don't know about this okay so that's
it actually I want to just quickly
summarize so there's really many
scenarios where the traditional view of
how secret keys are generated stored and
used does not hold so you know if things
like leakage of password and biometrics
and I think there's a lot of
opportunities here where better Theory
can lead to better security practice I
and there's a lot of good open questions
left here thank you
um probably not yet so but I think
eventually I think people are you know
people are starting to develop general
techniques I think they will probably be
at least in some very modified way
useful for actual practical
constructions later I think it's all how
it usually works in crypto he's an
earlier does that sound like the reason
that's something that you could think of
there's a big drawback that I didn't
mention so i'll mention it now which is
if the virus is actually you know let's
say you're like using this key to log
into your bank account right so then the
problem is if you have a virus on your
computer maybe if it's active it can
just like use your computer itself to
log into your bank account and do all
kinds of bad things from your own
computer and there's kind of no way to
prevent that so what we prevent this
like if the virus is active for a while
and tries to upload something or you
know upload something to remote attacker
then the remote attacker won't be able
to log into your bank account and you
know or if it's like you've logged in a
couple of times and done some things and
the virus is active later then you know
you have the attacker kind of saw this
communication they won't see what
happened you know it'll stay private but
but we can't kind of prevent so so I
think the reason people might not like
this is they'll always think oh the
virus will just do all the bad things it
wants to do while it's on the computer
itself but you know in some sense maybe
those attacks are more sophisticated
harder to implement so in this move this
might be reasonable in some cases
for all your results
not just the first thing first one yeah
have you thought of doing non-value
extractors in our computational sentence
which may be enough
yeah that's a good question I didn't
really think about it um I guess the
point is that you know if you care about
wiki's and things like that in a
computational sense we have kind of
different set of tools that can that can
do the same thing so wouldn't you you
wouldn't necessarily have to take this
approach with non malleable extractors
just just kind of really different ways
of doing it that we know of like for
example these public key encryption
schemes that we are secure with wikis
already kind of solved the problem in a
computational sense so so it's not clear
exactly you know I think if you were
thinking from a computational sense you
might probably want to take a completely
different approach but maybe that you
could think about like now mallu
extractors my computational side
photography it's much easier to come up
with a system that probably does work
than one that actually provably works do
you think in these cases that some of
the complexity is necessary to work at
all or is part of the complexity and
giving actual proof some do you think
the simpler systems my birth
yeah great question so I I think it
depends on the area so like for just
designing public key encryption schemes
that are secure with some partial
leakage but not continue leakage I think
pretty much any encryption scheme will
be secure at least in some sense with
some smoke Barcia leakage because so so
so there's I think I think it's mostly a
question of proofs like I think El Gamal
would probably be be secure like the
standard encryption scheme for continual
leakage I just don't know too much about
I just have no idea in some sense i have
no idea how to do the updates without i
don't see any natural schemes for doing
this that are much easier than what we
ended up doing so i think it really
depends on the area you're having a
secret key that's evolving does it seem
to be a very nice
emotions yeah yeah I just know a special
official solution for that yeah for
symmetric keep it crypt of people think
of that because they're you kind of it
doesn't have to remain consistent with
anything but for public key cryptography
realize we're on that show constructions
that are not secure just all
construction yeah exactly I I don't know
anything about it security listed it's
not like yeah I can't think of any way
to simplify the construction that that I
would conjecture would be secure but
just can't prove it yeah
yes